Okay, good morning. So today we are
doing Karx and Kar Marx is one of the
most influential thinkers in human
history. His contribution
um to in intellectual thought cannot be
um overstated. Okay. So um what I'm
going to do first is I'm going to do a
thought experiment. Okay. It's it's just
going to be a fun experiment. And let's
pretend there are two
scenarios. Okay. In scenario
one, you get into a really good college
and you decide to become a lawyer. Go to
law school. You do extremely well. You
become a lawyer and you make a lot of
money. When you make a lot of money, you
can buy a big house, go on vacations to
uh Bali. um you can you can um have a
BMW. Okay, so that's situation one.
You're you're a super lawyer basically.
Situation two is different. You're on a
plane with strangers and there's 100 of
you. You crash on an island. This
island, it's very poor, very scarce
resources and you have to work together
in order to just get by. Okay, you're
not eating well, you're not living well.
Every day is a struggle. you're not
really sure if you'll get to the second
day. All right, so those are the two
scenarios. You're on island and you're
basically like
starving. And so the question, the
thought experiment is do you think
you'll be a happier person in the first
situation or the second
situation? Now you of course. Yeah. So
you would think obviously the answer is
number one. But um what I will show you
today is that's not necessarily true.
Okay, maybe for some of us the answer is
number one, but for many of us the
answer actually number two because as
humans we want to feel as though we have
a purpose in life and that we are part
of a larger mission to change the world
for the better. Okay. And that's the
underlying thesis of Karl Marx. All
right. So let's start marks. Okay. So
first understand marks we first need to
review Kant and Hegel which we did last
class. So Emanuel Kant Emanuel Kant's um
theory of the world is this we are all
endowed with the capacity to
reason. Okay and it's born in us. Um we
don't learn it. It is just part of who
we are. Okay. So and then this reason
interacts with reality.
the things in themselves and then what
we see is the
appearance. Okay. So the crucial
argument that Khan is making is we
imagine reality around us by bringing in
space and time. Reality we we do not see
reality
objectively okay or away from us. We see
reality as part of us. And with our
minds we create our own universe.
And as we discussed last class, this has
been confirmed by neuroscience, by
artificial artificial intelligence,
micro mechanics. So it's really the
dominant understanding of human
psychology we have today. All right. But
the problem with Emanuel Kant, there are
three major issues with Emanuel Kant.
The first major issue
is if we can never know
reality, then how do we know what's real
and what's fake, right? H how do we know
we don't live in a computer simulation?
And the answer is we don't know. So
that's the first issue may caught. He
does not give us proof of an objective
reality. Okay, that's the first problem.
Second problem is the source for our
reason. If we are born with the capacity
to imagine space and time and shape our
reality, who gives it to us? Where does
it come from? and he doesn't really
answer that question. Right? The third
question is a problem of
uniformity which is to
say how do I know that
you and me and others see the world in
the same
way? Why aren't we seeing a different
reality? Okay. And then and then Khan
says, "Well, we don't know either."
Okay. So this these are the three major
problems created by MA Khan's philosophy
of the world. So Frederick Hegel comes
along and resolves all three issues.
Okay. What he says is this. He says like
the
underlying source of reality is called
the gist. The gist is a spirit of the
world. Think of it as a god that's
becoming into reality. It's growing.
Okay? It's almost like the internet uh
collective consciousness. And as a
result, the gist is giving us the
capacity to reason and to see itself and
then to imagine our own reality. Okay.
So the idea of the gist solves all three
problems at once. An underlying reality
that gives um uh that creates the
material reality. So Heggo is an
idealist meaning for him what matters is
ideas and spirit and the material what
is created from these ideas and from
spirit. Okay. So these are the so what
this is Hegel what Karl Marx will do is
build on Hegel to create something
called dialectical materialism which is
idea of class struggle okay and he will
create this philosophy based on his
reading of Hegel. All right so let's um
go over how
Markx interprets Hegel. So
again Hegel has three
major ideas. The first is the idea of
the gist. Okay. The underlying
superructure of
reality. Second is the idea of the
dialectic. Okay. So the idea of the
dialectic is how does this guys become
what it does? What it is? How does this
guys learn and think? And the answer is
the dialectic. The dialectic is
thesis,
antithesis and
synthesis. And the concept is just a
debate among in itself. For it to know
itself, it must create its opposite. And
then when it creates its opposite, it
debates itself and creates a synthesis.
Okay? And it's the idea of a debate
where you might have a viewpoint and you
engage with someone with another
viewpoint that's opposite of yours. you
debate and through this debate you
create a symphysis of your different
viewpoints. Okay. And for Hegel this is
the under underlying logic of history of
how we learn of how we progress. Okay.
And the third idea that Hegel proposes
is ide of the master slave
dialectic. And so um Hegel thinks that
relationship can be broken into a master
and slave. Basically I command you, you
do as I say, you obey me. But when but
then what Hegel says is over time this
thesis interis also becomes a symphysis.
Why? Because as your master as your
master I become dependent on you as my
slave. In fact you're the one doing all
the work. So without you I can't exist.
Okay. So in this way the relationship
inverts itself and the master becomes
slave to the slave right because the
master is now dependent on the slave for
his livelihood. All right so those these
are the three big ideas that Hegel is
going to take sorry these are the three
big ideas of Hegel and Marx is going to
take these three ideas and develop his
own theory of the world. So Markx Marx
is from
Prussia.
Um as we discussed uh before a lot of
these major philosophers are from
Prussia. Hegel himself was also Prussian
and he was very proud to be to be
Prussian. Um and Marx when he was in
university was part of a group called
the young Hegelians. These are
individuals uh a group of them who
worship Hegel but they misinterpreted
Hegel. Okay? They thought of Hegel as an
atheist um because he said God is dead.
But when Hegel said God is dead, what he
really meant is I am now going to
reinterpret God not as this separate
entity from us but as part of us in the
form of the guys. Okay. Um so the young
aliens will reinterpret Hegel and
basically misinterpret him. So the first
thing they do is they take the guys and
they turn into a material
thing. Okay.
economics. So Hegel thinks it's ideas
that come first then material reality.
But these guys, the young Hegelian, they
will invert this and say it's material
reality that creates ideas. Okay? It's
economics, it's wealth that creates
culture which gives rise to ideas. Okay?
So it's the complete opposite. Um second
thing they'll do is if this is true the
dialectic and the master slave
relationship um then history is a
history of oppression and a struggle for
liberation against this oppression.
Okay. And so the idea of the uh material
world in struggle with itself creates
the idea of
dialectical materialism. And we call
this class struggle.
Okay. The rich and the poor fun each
each other and the poor are looking for
liberation. Right? So does that make
sense? Yes. Okay. Great. So um that's
right. So this is class struggle and
this is the main contribution that Markx
will make and by creating this idea he
will lay the foundation for what we
refer to as
communism. All right. The underlying
reality of history is class struggle.
The other thing that marks will take
from Hegel is an understanding that all
of history is
theological. Teological. Okay, this is a
big word, but all it means is there is
an inevitability to history. There's a
purpose. There's a progress to history.
Everything is being done for a reason.
Okay, so let's go over the theology that
marks great. All right, so we were born
as hunter gatherers. We all know
this, okay? We're out in the out in the
forest hunting food and small tribes and
we're happy, but there's not enough food
to feed everyone. So we develop
agriculture, right? And then because of
agriculture, we have something called
surplus value. we're able to create more
wealth which allows a few of us to
settle down and do other stuff for
example create literacy okay and this
gives rise to
civilization and then to justify the
civilization to justify this hierarchy
the fact that you have a few people who
are essentially parasites of society we
create the idea of religion right
because the elite now are priests All
right. So that's the second stage. Then
what happens is
um as we develop more and more
technology and the societies become
larger and larger, we have to go to war
against each other. Okay. To fight for
resources. And so this gives rise to the
master slave
relationship which then gives us
feudalism. Okay. which then allows for
the rise of industrial
capitalism. And this is a stage Markx
finds himself
at. And what Markx says is this is all a
linear progress driven by technological
advancement, right? Agriculture is an
advancement. And then you have tools,
you have weapons, um then you have
castles, knights, and now you have steam
ships. Okay? So it's all part of a
technological plan to liberate
humanity technology.
Okay. Now, and he's writing the year in
1848. Okay. Um and now now industrial
capitalism will naturally lead to
communism. All right. He says this this
is not something that we can hope for or
work towards. It's something that's
going to happen because of history.
Okay. History is God. God is history. We
our world has been developed through the
mind of God. All right. So um first
thing he does is he uses the Heg
Hegelian dialectic. Right? So feudalism
is the thesis, industrial capitalism is
antithesis and then together they will
create
communism. Why? Okay. So for Marx
embedded in
capitalism is
the seeds of its demise and there are
three reasons why. Okay. First is
industrial
capitalism is imperial. It's all
consumer. It
expands and as a result it's going to
create a global politariat. And because
they're all oppressed, they're going to
come in consciousness together and
recognize that only for collective
action can we liberate ourselves from
the capitalist class. All right? And
because the polit is the majority of
people, 99% then 1% have no have no
chance. Okay? That's number one. Number
two is the idea of
technology. Capitalism gives rise to to
new technology which makes sur which
creates surplus value and surplus labor.
It basically makes our job easier. Okay,
which case we don't have to work as hard
as before in order to create
value. Okay, so that's technology. So
for for example AI,
right? And the third is the idea of
crisis in capitalism.
Okay, crisis in capitalism. And what
this means is for Markx, capitalism is
fundamentally unsustainable. It will
collapse at a certain point. Why? Well,
there are many reasons why. Okay, so for
Marks, the main problem is overp
production. You're producing all these
goods, but because you're impoverishing
everyone, no one's going to buy these
goods, in which case the markets, in
which case the economy's going to
collapse. Right? That's one um
possibility. Another possibility is
presented by a man named Thomas
Okay. And he wrote a famous book called
capital in the 21st century. And he's
working off marks. And what he believes
the fundamental uh paradox of capitalism
is is a problem of uh
financialization. So all this is saying
is
this at first we have to build a factory
to generate wealth, right? But once we
have gen enough wealth, we want to take
this wealth and go invest it somewhere
because it's easier for us and we can
make more money that way. But over time
as capitalism grows and grows, everyone
wants to invest. No one wants to
manufacture. And what happens then is
the financial economy is growing faster
than the manufacturing economy. In fact,
for picody, the financial economy will
go at 5% whereas the manufacturing
economy will go at 2%. This means that
if you put your money in a stock market,
you'll make 5% a year. But if you open a
restaurant or you create a factory or
you do something useful, you make 2% a
year. So no one wants to work anymore,
right? So for Piggity, capitalism will
have to end at some point. Then you have
a name named Carol Quigley and he's a
historian. Uh we discussed him uh last
week, but he's a historian at
Georgetown. He's dead, but he wrote of a
famous book called Tragedy and Hope. And
he argues that capitalism goes in
phases. The first phase is consumer
capitalism where companies are trying to
create products that consumers want to
buy. Then that leads to financial
capitalism where now companies just want
to invest their wealth. But over time
the final stage is the idea of monopoly
capitalism where a few companies control
all the
resources. Okay? In which case uh we pay
a lot of money for crappy stuff. and
then we don't want to buy anything
anymore. Okay. So,
uh for Marx and for and for Carol
quickly capitalism can only lead to
crisis and then because of the crisis
the politer will organize
um and then rebel and then create a
workers's paradise. Okay. Which leads to
communism. That's the logic of Marx.
That is Marx's understanding of history.
Okay. All right. So what I'm going to
explain now is why would this be
popular? Why would this history be
popular for people? Because communism
was one of the most popular movements um
throughout the 20th century. Okay. And
the problem that marks diagnosis is
capitalism makes people miserable for
three
reasons. Okay. Okay. So the issues of
capitalism the first issue is that it is
all encompassing all
consuming. So in other words it just
grows and grows and because it has to
grow and grow to create value it starts
worse. So you have imperialism right?
Because as a factory owner you want to
create new markets. You want access to
cheaper goods. You want access to
cheaper labor. Therefore, you force your
government to go invade other countries
like China,
India, Africa. Okay? So, capitalism
creates wars and human misery all around
the world. It's all consuming. It's
always expanding. Okay. Second problem
with capitalism is that it is it
consolidates
consolidating. And the idea here is this
capitalism can only lead to extreme
inequality. Why? Because the point of
capitalism is to generate as much wealth
as possible. So to do that, we want to
consolidate our wealth. So maybe there's
10 of us with a million dollars each,
right? Well, we're better off just put
putting our money together and then
investing it together, right? Which
creates massive
inequality. So over time, Markx believes
that because capitalism is all consuming
and consolidating, it will destroy the
middle class. Unless you're super
wealthy, um you won't have any money.
Okay? If you are just like a small
factory owner, you'll be bought out by a
large factory owner. And quite honestly,
this is what's happening in the world
today. Okay? If you are a small house
owner in America, well, um you're going
to be bought out by a company and then
the company's going to use your house to
rent to other people. Okay? So, this
this is a pattern that's happening
throughout the world today. And that's
why Marx is seeing a massive resurgence
in our world today. Right? Now the third
problem
um is
alienating and here Markx explains that
there are four types of alienation.
Okay, the first type of alienation is
the alienation of labor and what this
means is this. As humans we want to
create stuff. We are fundamentally
creative. We want to create art
products. We want to cook. We want to
teach. We want to express our
individuality. Okay. And why we want to
do that is when we express our
individuality, when we create things, we
um support the community, right? So when
I teach uh you guys, you guys learn and
when you learn, you um feel good, you
thank me and that confirms my humanity,
that confirms my individuality. So
society is a mechanism for each of us to
exchange
um um our creativity in a way that
affirms our own individuality. Okay,
does that make sense? All right. The
problem with capitalism is it takes use
value, okay, what this thing is used for
and replace it for like exchange
value, okay, which is how much this
thing is worth. And that's this is these
are two different opposites. Okay. Oh,
sorry. These are two different concepts.
So, use value is I cook I cook a apple
pie and then I give it to you and you
eat it and you say, "Wow, this is a
really awesome apple pie. Thank you so
much." And then you feel good. I feel
good. Okay, that's use value. Exchange
value is I cook this apple pie and I
give it to someone who then goes sells
to someone. I never meet that person.
Okay, and I'm not and and I don't know
what happens to the pie, but I'm paid
like $5 for it. Right? So that's the
idea of exchange value. And as such,
what Marxist says is this exchange of
goods does not affirm our individuality.
Therefore, it makes us miserable because
we don't know why we're doing anything
anymore. Okay? Before we were doing
things in order to support our
community, in order to please other
people, in order to affirm our humanity.
Now we're just making stuff because of
wage labor, right? Wages to get paid.
Okay? So that's alienating for us. Okay,
this this makes sense, right?
Great. Second is that it alienates us
from ourselves. Why? Because as human
beings, we are very complex. We are
multifaceted and we're always evolving.
But for capitalism, what matters is
division of labor, okay? Specialization
because that's what allows for the most
rapid industrial growth. And so in other
words, you cease to be you and you
become a hand or maybe a finger or maybe
an eye or maybe an ear, okay? But you
cease to be complete. You just be you're
you're just like a in the machine.
You're just a piece of the puzzle and
that alienates you from who you are
really. It it it prevents you from
achieving your full potential as a
creative vibrant human being. Okay,
that's second issue. The third issue is
it alienates us from nature.
Okay. Why?
Because capitalism grows by exploiting
humans and by exploiting nature. It cuts
down trees. It destroys the environment.
It creates air pollution. Uh we we can
no longer drink drink drink clean water.
Okay? It destroys nature and it makes us
feel like we must destroy nature if we
are to feed our families. So it
alienates us from our nature. Whereas
historically we have feel we we we have
been in a symbotic relationship with
nature where we thank nature for feeding
us but we're always replenishing we're
always protecting nature right the
fourth type of alienation is the
alienation from
humanity right so before from for most
of history we were cooperating with each
other we're helping each other out okay
because that's the only way you could
survive but capitalism forces us to
compete against each other Okay. And the
example of course is school where
because of grades you see your
classmates as competitors, right? But if
there are no grades, then you might help
each other learn. You might um um tutor
each other in in homework and help each
other with homework and tests. Okay.
Okay. So So that does that make sense?
So the idea here is let's just say that
um like like maybe five people are have
to carry some goods to a store. Okay,
that that's your job. One person falls
down, breaks his leg, and cries out for
help. Well, we should go help that
person, right? But the logic of
capitalism is you can't the logic of
capitalism is you can't do that
because the manager will find you for
being
late. Okay, does that make sense? All
right, so that that that's why Markx
thinks that this will alien us from our
humanity. And this part of Markx where
Markx diagnoses the problems of
capitalism is considered brilliant.
Okay, this is a perfect encapsulation of
all the issues with capitalism that was
true in the 1850s in the 19th century,
but it's also true today. If you look at
the world today, then we also have these
issues. And if you can if you analyze
Marxist diagnosis of capitalism, then it
helps explain why the world is the way
it is. Okay. All right. So, and because
of these pressing issues, because people
are suffering so much, they see Marxism,
they see communism as salvation and
redemption. That's the appeal. Okay?
Because capitalism has made life so
miserable for a majority of people.
Okay? All right. So, but the problem is
we
know
that
this prophecy of Marx that we will
naturally evolve into communism has not
panned out. In fact, communism has
caused a lot of human misery as well.
And so, why is that the case? And so
what I'm going to show you now is even
though Markx has this beautiful theory,
it's also wrong. Okay, for a variety of
reasons. So let's analyze his
understanding of history and show how
it's wrong. Okay, the first thing is
um let's go back to huntergatherer
agriculture transition. The first class
I ever taught um like a long long time
ago is the transition from hunter gather
culture didn't make any sense as a
hunter gatherer. You didn't have a
scarcity problem. In fact, you ate
really well. You work less, you ate
more. And we know because if you dig up
skeletons of hunter gatherers, they're
taller than farmers. In fact, they're a
lot taller. Hunter gathers were on
average like six six foot. Okay, which
is like really really tall, right? And
farmers were like on average maybe five
foot. That's a huge difference. Okay. So
the so using the economic argument of
marks, this makes no sense, right? And
what I explained to you before is it's
not economics that drives human history.
It's religion that drives human history.
Okay? So we settle down in order to
practice a cult to practice a religion
because maybe one place was considered
divine for whatever reason. And as a
result, we developed our culture which
led to civilization. So the marks
formulation that religion comes last is
wrong. It's religion that comes first.
Okay? It's religion that leads to
agriculture which leads to
civilization. Right? So that's what
Markx gets wrong. Also um the transition
from feudalism to capitalism was not
driven by technology. It was driven by
religion. All right. So let me explain.
Okay. So the feudalism the dominant
religion at the time was the Catholic
religion. When we when we go into
industrial capitalism the dominant
religion is protestimism.
Okay. So as we discussed before the
Catholic religion was an imperial
bureaucracy
uh led by the pope and there were many
religious reformers who thought this was
abhorrent. This went against the will of
God. Okay. And so what they proposed was
this. They proposed a religion which was
democratic in which everyone had access
to God. Okay? Before you had to listen
to the priests, you couldn't read the
Bible by yourself. Now you had to read
the Bible yourself in order to access
God by yourself. Okay? And there were
two major different there were two major
transitions. Um the first is before in
order to get to heaven you had to use
justification by
works. All this means is you do good
things. You give money to the church.
you primarily give money to the church.
Okay. All right. But because the
Protestants want to reduce the power of
the Catholic church, they said, "No,
what matters is justification by faith.
It doesn't matter how much money you
give to the church. What matters is do
you truly believe in God?" Okay, that's
what matters. So that's the first major
difference. Uh and then the process in
in order to reduce the power of the
church uh because the church said only
if you listen to us can we guarantee you
access to heaven. Right? So what the
protest said is no um access to heaven
is predestined. Uh so they have
predestination. In other words, at the
beginning of time, God has already
decided who will go to heaven and who
will go to
hell. He's already decided. So doesn't
matter what the church tells you. It
doesn't matter how much money you give
to the church, you're all going to hell
if you don't believe truly believe in
God. All right? So so the Protestant
religion was a direct response to the
Catholic religion. Now this creates a
new problem. Okay, the problem is this.
How do you know you truly believe in
God? How do you know that you are one of
the elect? How do you know that you were
chosen by God to go to heaven? This
creates anxiety, right? Anxiety as we
know leads to OCD, obsessivecompulsive
disorder, right? So how do you
compensate for OCD? Well, you make a lot
of money. But not only do you make a lot
of money, but you don't spend it.
Because that wealth now is an indicator
to you and to others that you are truly
one of the elect, that you are saved by
God, that you were chosen by God to go
to heaven. And that's the birth of
capitalism. Okay? Does that make sense?
All right. It was not technologydriven
because the technology at that time was
everywhere. But it was only in Europe
did you have industrial capitalism. It
was because of the Protestant faith.
That's what drove it.
like making so many wealth can be a
promise to God. Okay. Um so you're
generating this wealth not to appease
God but to impeach your anxiety. Do you
understand this? You won't give money to
this to God because God doesn't need
your money. Okay. But having this money
is confirmation to yourself that you
will go to heaven because this money can
only be made because of your faith in
God. Do you understand? Okay. How do you
know you believe in God? because you
worked hard and God made you wealthy and
that's the logic driving capitalism. So
Markx missed
this. Okay. So um so let's summarize and
say look Marx made three fund
fundamental mistakes. The first is
people care about religion not
economics. Okay it's religion that
drives human history not economics.
That's the first mistake he made. Second
mistake that he made
is people care about God, not
heaven. Okay? In other words, we're
going to heaven not because we think
it's a fivestar hotel with like lots and
lots of like I don't know like lobsters
and steaks and all you eat buffets.
That's not the reason we're going to
heaven. We're going to heaven to be with
God because God represents eternal
truth, eternal salvation. We want to be
with God. Okay. The third is people care
about status not class. So in other
words um throughout most of human
history we didn't have a concept of
money. So for example the Vikings um
when they went off to steal they stole
lots of gold right but the but when they
got back to the village they would host
hold a big feast for everyone and they
would waste all this money. You
understand? Because the point because
you there there's absolutely no point in
having money. You couldn't spend it. If
you died, you couldn't keep it. So So
you you made money. You generate wealth
in order to raise your status within the
community. Okay? And that's why you wore
gold because the gold signify that
you're of high status within the
community. All right? So throughout most
of of human history and still even
today, we seek status, not class. The
class the concept of class is created
because of industrial capitalism,
because of the free market. Okay,
because now people were mobile.
Okay, but before it was about status.
Okay, and so what this means is this.
Because Marx interpreted history
incorrectly and he didn't really
understand human
psychology. What he could not predict is
when we did achieve communism it would
be it would
become bureaucratic hierarchies with
core of
personalities include in the Soviet
Union you had Stalin right it was in
charge of a bureaucracy and in China you
had Maon who had who was in charge of
bureaucracy. North Korea the same same
situation. Why? Why? Because of these
three factors, right? Ma Stalin all
understood that people want a
religion. They want to be they want to
feel close to God. So they made
themselves God. Okay? And people want
status. And that's why it's important to
have a
bureaucracy. So that's why colon
communism became the way it became in
the 20th
century. All right. Okay. So does this
make sense? All right. Great. All right.
So the So even though the Mark's
philosophy is very appealing, it's very
clear, it's very direct, it's very sexy,
he got he got the history wrong and and
and and because he got the history
wrong, the consequences were huge. Okay?
Because um communism created a lot of
wars and it led to a lot of disasters
like famines and stuff. Okay, any
questions before I move on?
some of the faults
of
emp China and so
okay yeah so that's a really good
question Um and so the question is the
role of religion should be obvious to
people, right? Why do they believe in
economics? Yeah. Okay. Okay. Um that's a
great question. And you know what? I
don't have an answer, but I think a clue
is this. Capitalism and communism are
the same
religion. Okay? So as capitalism grows,
it reinforces communism. As communism
grows, it reinforces capitalism. Why?
Because both believe that economics,
materialism is the underlying
reality. Okay? Religion doesn't matter.
So, capitalism spreads by making
everyone uniform, by turning everyone
into an economic animal, right? Because
today, we don't ask you to believe in
God. We ask you to go buy
things. Does that does that make sense?
Communism is the same way. Communism
believes that as long as there's
equality, as long there's no property,
everyone will be happy. So, it's ironic
that these two ideas, capitalism and
communism, even though they were mortal
enemies in the 20th century, the
underlying basis of the religion is the
same. And as they develop, they
reinforce each other. Okay, that does
that make sense? All right. So, but that
that that's a great question, right? So
we instantly understand that religion is
more important than economics. But
because capitalism and communism were
able to spread so fast, we've been
brainwashed into thinking that only
economics
matters. Okay? So for example, when you
read the newspaper, it's always what's
the GDP this year? What's the employment
rate this year? What's the inflation
rate this year? What's the price of eggs
this year? It's never how do people feel
spiritually? How how are how how are
people religiously? Okay, it's never
about your psychology. Never it's never
about your spirituality. It's always
about how much money do you have? Okay.
So so communism and capitalism together
conquer the
world. Does that make sense? Yeah. Okay.
Great. Any more questions before I move
on? But why this kind of is fit for
China
or not?
Okay, this is a great question. So Markx
himself
um believed the revolution will happen
in Germany first because Germany had the
most advanced
proletariat. Um but it never happened in
Germany. It didn't happen in France. It
didn't happen in Britain. It happened in
China and the and Russia. And in fact,
if Markx were alive today, he would be
appalled by the fact that happened in
Russia and China because it wasn't
supposed to happen in Russia and China.
You needed a proletariat in order for
the revolution to happen. But Russia and
China were peasant nations, right? So
what had happened in um uh Russia and
China, okay, the main reason is this. Um
and we'll go more into this next week.
Okay, the main reason is this. Because a
communist revolution was not a communist
revolution. It was a peasant revolution
with the veneer of communism. So
communism was the ideology, the religion
that they practiced, but it was
essentially a peasant rebellion that's
no different from previous peasant
rebellions in Chinese history. Okay.
Does that make sense? All right. But but
I'll explain this later on. All right.
Great. But great question. And any more
questions be before I move on? Great.
All right. So what but was this clear to
you this history? Okay. All right. Good.
And it's very important because um it
really helps you understand the world we
live in today because even though uh
Marx's theory of history is wrong, his
understanding of capitalism is is
perfect. Okay. Uh and it it really helps
you think about why things are happening
the way they are today. Especially the
constellation of wealth. All right.
Let's do the history. Okay. All right.
So
um okay we did Kant and Hegel
um on Tuesday we're doing Markx today
next Tuesday we do Freud okay why are we
doing these four thinkers because you're
the ones each of them who created
intellectual revolution that
fundamentally changed the way we see
ourselves and society okay so remember
Kant made us subjective okay he taught
us that the world does not exist is
outside us. Hegel taught us that there's
a gist that
uh compels us into okay we we are just a
manifestation of this guys. Okay. But
the gist is everything. Markx teaches
teaches us it's class struggle that's
the underlying force of history. Okay.
And what he also believes is the class
struggle can only end in communism. Why?
Because that is the will of God. because
God manifests itself in our history. All
right. So Markx is really building on
top of Hegel. What what we will learn
next Tuesday is Freud. Okay. So and
Freud is going to work on all three to
build a new theory of the world. And the
theory is um amazing because what he
does is
um he takes all these theories and
teaches us that we are our own universe.
effing that happens is because of our
memories and our psychology. Okay, but
that's next Tuesday. Um, but just to
give you a heads up. All right, so um
the entire lecture is about why was
Markx
wrong. Okay. And as explained the marks
I mean he was like a prophet, right? Um
he comes from a Jewish family. He
himself was an atheist but he came from
a long line of Jewish Jewish rabbis. And
when I say that, you're like, "Oh, okay,
that doesn't sound that impressive." But
it was basically the equivalent of
saying he came from 10 generations of
Harvard professors. That's really
impressive, right? So, I mean, uh, he
was a genius. His entire family were
geniuses. Remember, the Jews are very
intellectual people. They were the
people of the book. And the rabbis are
the most intellectual members of the
community. They're the leaders of the
community. So, Markx comes more ex he's
basically an aristocrat. Okay. Um, so
he's he's almost like a prophet. I mean
he is a prophet he's a poet prophet
who's preaching of a new world to come
and he's very uh certain he's very clear
and he's very optimistic and that's his
appeal okay but I explained that's al
that was also his downfall he was too
simple in his understanding of human
history all right so um industrial
capitalism is coming to Europe and it
makes everyone miserable uh it's it's
it's destroying society because it's
taking all these people from the
villages and transporting into the
cities without adequate housing, without
adequate health care, uh
um work safety. The they're they're in
these slums. They don't have access to
clean water. A lot of them are dying. Um
their children are being forced to work
um from age five or six. It's all
polluted. Okay? So, people are living in
absolute misery. Okay? Especially
children. And this is causing a lot of
anger. What really does it is in the
1840s there's a massive potato famine
all
across Europe. Okay, so remember um in
the 16th century the Europeans, the
Spanish discovered the new world and
they brought back the potato. Why is
that important? Because a potato will
allow Europe to grow its population very
very fast in order to uh feed its
economic needs. The problem though is
when you rely on a single crop, the
potato, it's prone to disease. Okay. So
the potato because of it lack of
diversity um it it it created a famine
throughout uh Europe. Tens of millions
of people died in this famine and so a
lot of them uh immigrated over to the
new world America and South America.
Okay. Uh the worst hit part of Europe of
course was Ireland. So as you can see
only Dublin ma ma managed to maintain or
increase its population. Everywhere else
saw a massive decrease in its
population. The red represents a
population decrease of 30% or more in
the span of a few years. Okay. From 1841
to 1851, 10
years. Okay. So this was a massive
traumatic event in Europe and this led
to
um sorry this led to massive uprisings
throughout Europe. Okay. And this is
what
inspired Markx and angles to write the
communist manifesto because they
believed a new order was coming and we
have to prepare for it. Okay. Now what
will happen is the 1848 revolutions are
calling for three things. They're
calling for nationalism nation states
based on France. They're calling for
liberalism more political rights and
socialism more worker rights. And it's
all happening throughout Europe. But and
so Markx and angles is convinced
paradise is coming but ultimately the
authorities crack down but marks and
angles are still convinced paradise is
coming at any point. Okay. So they
dedicate their entire lives to um um
imagining this new world. The communist
manifesto was published in 1848
um in in
in anticipation of this polit victory
over the capitalist class. Okay. And it
is an amazing document. It's beautifully
written. I I I don't think they get
enough credit for how wonderful this is
written. Okay. But but but let's read
the beginning, right? A spectre is
haunting Europe. The spectre of
communism. So the spectre is important
because remember it's the gist, right?
Hegel said that the underlying force of
the world is the gist. And what they're
saying is the gist is communism.
Communism is the future. It is what will
happen. Okay. All the powers of old
Europe have entered into into a holy
alliance to exercise inspector Pope
Ensar. Okay. So all the authorities of
the world are afraid of this guys. But
this guys is God. So it will triumph
eventually.
Okay.
Um let's read the end. To this end,
communists of various nationalities have
assembled in London and sketched the
following manifesto to be published in
the English, French, German, Italian,
Flemish, and Danish languages. This is
really important because this is the one
of the first international revolutions.
It's going to sweep all around the
world. Okay, replace capitalism.
Capitalism is only the building block
for
communism.
Okay. Um, the communist manifesto, it is
powerful. Uh it's wonderfully written.
It's poetry. And I think that over the
next few years as the cap economic
crisis worsens around the world, people
are going to refer back to the communist
manifesto. Okay. But this is really the
best part of communist manifesto where
Marx and Angles diagnose the problems of
capitalism. Okay.
The bourgeozi, the capitalist class,
wherever it has got the upper hand, has
put an end to all feudal patriarchal
ideic relations. It has pitously torn a
shunder the mildly feudal ties that
bound men to his natural superiors and
has left remaining no other nexus
between men and men than naked
self-interest than callous self cash
payment. Okay. So remember capitalism it
is an all expanding all encompassing
allconsuming alienating force and it's
destroying the world. But for marks and
angles this is good because it will lead
to the rise of communism right this is
part of the thesis antithesis symphysis
part of
history. Um the so the bor are engaged
in uh imperialism. It's destroying all
that we've known before to create a new
man, an e economic man only based on
self-interest. It's even destroying the
family. Okay? So, you no longer see
yourself as a son or a father as a
husband. You see yourself as a man who
makes $10,000 a year or $50,000 a year
and is able to buy, I don't know, a car
or whatever. Okay? So, that's the power
of capitalism. But again for Marx angles
this is good because now it will lead to
communism where this new consciousness
will transform into a class
solidarity. Okay this makes sense right?
Okay so Markx's most famous work is
capital and he spent decades running
writing this. The problem with Markx is
that he's a brilliant man. He's he's one
of the most brilliant men who ever lived
but he's extremely undisiplined. He
procrastinates all the time. So he
actually never finished this book in his
life. It's Frederick Engles who um who
was his best friend, his collaborator,
but Frederick Engles was a very
disciplined individual. So it's
Frederick Engles who put this book
together. Okay. All
right. All right. So as I mentioned,
what's really important for us to
understand is that Markx he's a prophet.
He doesn't think of himself as a
prophet. He doesn't know he's a prophet,
but he's really a prophet. And as such,
what he's really doing is he's just
building on top of Christianity. Okay?
He's just extending the logic of
Christianity, right? So let let's see
how let's see what he does. Christianity
is a passive religion. You don't really
have to do anything. Just don't commit
any sins and then you go to heaven.
Okay? But for Markx, what's important is
that we participate in the revolution.
That we are responsible for our lives.
Okay. Second difference is Christianity
argues that only a few can go to heaven.
You they argue about who will go to
heaven but only a few okay only a
minority of the people. Okay that's why
you have he hell purgatory and heaven
three different places but for marks he
believes that work is paradise can be
achieved for everyone.
Okay. Um and the third difference is
Christianity offers a heaven with God.
Markx offers a utopia about God. The
problem is this. No one wants utopia
about God. Okay, we we discussed this
where if heaven was just a five-star
hotel where you can eat all the best
food in the world, no one would want to
go. People are going to heaven for God.
Okay, and this is why uh Mars cannot
anticipate the rise of people like
Stalin and
Madon. Okay. Um this is a letter that
Markx wrote in his early years and it is
probably in my opinion his best piece of
writing because it really shows you his
thinking his optimism his idealism.
Okay. So so let's read it together.
Supposing that we have produced in human
manner in this production each of us
would have doubly affirmed himself and
his fellow man. I would objectify in my
production my individuality and its
peculiarity and would thus have enjoyed
in my activity an individual expression
of my life and would have had also had
and look at the object the individual
pleasure of realizing that my
personality was objective. Okay, does
that make sense? So you're creating
something. This thing is the perfect
expression of your individuality, of
your personality, of your creativity.
And then you share with other people and
they enjoy it. And that and and because
they enjoy it, that process affirms your
individuality and your creativity, your
validation basically. Okay. Right.
I would have been for you the mediator
between you and the species and thus
have been felt by you and acknowledged
as a completion of your own essence and
a necessary part of yourself and I would
then thereby have realized that I was
confirmed both in your thought and in
your love. Okay. So when I cook a meal
and you enjoy the meal um you're not
only affirming my individuality but
you're affirming my connection to all of
humanity. Okay? Because you're telling
me that I contribute positively to the
species.
Right.
Um the problem is this pre presupposing
private property my individuality is so
far ex externalized that I hate my
activity. It is a torment to me and only
the appearance of an activity and thus
also merely a force activity that is
laid upon me through an external
arbitrary need not an inner and
necessary one. Okay. So this is
complicated but all all he's saying is
this. I cook you a meal. I spent days
preparing this meal. Okay. I put it's a
labor of love. I cook the best food in
the world. Okay, I give it to you. You
have you are blown away. You are you
you're in love, okay, with this food.
And then you're
like, here's
$1,000, right? That's
disgusting, right? All you have to do is
say thank you, but then say you give me
$1,000. And you think, wow, I'm giving
you $1,000. That's a lot of money, man.
I pay you know I don't pay this much at
a restaurant. Okay. So that's what Markx
is saying. The moment you put money into
the equation, it destroys all human
relations, right? So he's talking about
extrinsic motivation whereas versus
intrinsic motivation. Intrinsic
intrinsic motivation is what makes us
fundamentally human. Extrinsic
motivation is what makes us
slaves. Okay. So that's what Markx is
saying. Capitalism makes us slaves
because it der deprivives us of our
humanity. Okay. That's what money does.
So, so does this make sense to you?
Yeah. Great. All right. So, again, um
let's just summarize what the failings
of capitalism are. Okay. Uh it creates
inequality, it exploits, and it
alienates, right? So, for Markx and
Engles, the antithesis will be class
solidarity and this will lead to a
classist workers paradise. Okay? That's
the very logic of Marxism.
Um so again marks what he will do is he
will invert Hegel right so for Hegel
it's the ideas that come first then this
will lead to the material reality for
Markx it's the material reality that
gives rise to ideas okay what what so
the ideas is called the superstructure
the base uh the base is the economics
okay so this is a very important idea of
um Markx so Marx diagnoses the problems
of capitalism really really Well, okay.
And he
offers solutions. And what's really
important is one reason why communism
has failed is capitalism has actually
adopted a lot of these policy changes.
Okay? Including universal child
education, including uh the univers
universal right to work, including ab
abolition of child factory labor. Okay?
So in many ways communism has won out
and Marx didn't really predict this
because he thought that capitalists are
idiots. Capitalist all they care about
is money. So there's like servants to
capital. They're not really in control.
And if you're a capitalist and you have
any empathy for the working class, guess
what? You're bought out or you're pushed
out of the capitalist class. Okay? So
it's only the worst people who can
thrive within the capitalist system. But
because communism was such a huge threat
to the ruling elite, they had no choice
to make compromises. Okay? And that's
why after World War II, most countries
in the world became socialists even
though in name they were still
capitalists. Okay. So let's we summarize
and this is really important for us.
Okay. But what are the four things Markx
got wrong? Okay. The first thing
is Markx believed that history is a
linear progress. It's it's a straight
line of in ineability of progress but
that's not true. Okay, history repeats
itself. That's the first issue. Second
issue is
um Mark's belief in the inability of
history but there's always randomness
built into history. Okay, things happen
and we don't expect these things to
happen. Third is Markx believe class
struggle with everything but people care
actually a lot more about religion than
they care about economics. All
right. And you know, this is a huge
issue in America because with the rest
of Donald Trump, the Democratic Party,
they don't know what to do about this
because they're like, you know, Trump
says that he will lower the price of
eggs, but he hasn't lowered the price of
eggs. So, like, stop voting for him. And
what the Democrats don't understand
is people want to believe in God. People
want a leader. People want a religion.
And Trump for all his feelings he
understands that and gives people what
they really want which is emotional
solidarity. Okay. A belief in a better
world. Last thing Marx believe a
vanguard need to lead the politariat
into a into a paradise. Okay. So Marx
really believed that you need an elite
of intellectuals, scientists,
technocrats to create the perfect
society. But then the question then is
why would they give power? Right? Once
they had once they have this power, why
do they give it up? And the answer is
they wouldn't give it up. Okay? And
that's why communism ultimately fails in
the Soviet Union and in China. Okay? All
right. This makes sense, right? All
right. So, so, so, so let's um go into
specifics. Um, in this class, what you
learn is it's not class struggle by
itself that causes discontent. It's
three other things. Okay. The first is
elite over overp production. So a really
important principle is history is not
fought over between the poor and the
rich. It's fought over between the very
rich and the not so rich. Okay? The
upper nobility and the lower nobility.
Right? Because Marx came from Jewish
aristocracy. Angles his father was a
very wealthy capitalist. Okay? These are
people with a lot and they wanted more.
Does that make sense? So when you have
too many
people seeking too much wealth and
status, it creates conflict. Okay,
that's the first thing. Second thing is
the idea of rat utopia where people live
too long. They live too long, they
refuse to give up power, they refuse to
innovate, they refuse to seed status to
the young. Okay. The third is the idea
of financialization as we discussed um
um Thomas Pity and Carol quickly provide
this idea where over time to make to
make more money all capitalists will do
is force everyone into more debt. Okay.
And these are the three factors that
cause society to um ultimately
destabilize.
Right? Clear? Great. All right. So,
let's look at three examples. All right.
You look at Soviet Union, you look at um
China, you look at France. How was it
possible for the Soviet Union to defeat
Germany? And Germany was at that time
the most advanced military in the world,
right? How did China the Chinese economy
boom after the cultural revolution? And
how did Napoleonic France defeat all of
Europe? Okay, so what we need to
understand is these were not communist
revolutions. Okay, these were just
revolutions that destroyed the old
elite. And all this is saying is
this people are playing a game in
society. Over time you have a few
winners who monopolize this game and
this causes discontent. What revolutions
do is they reset the game and that
creates a lot of energy, right? Right?
Because people now want to work hard to
win the game. Because of this energy,
they're able to defeat their opponents.
The same thing with the cultural
revolution where the cultural revolution
removed the old elite, the bureaucrats.
So in the 1980s when trying to open up,
you have these young people with
entrepreneurial drive to start
companies. But without the culture
revolution, this entrepreneur
entrepreneurial drive could not have
succeeded. Okay? Does that make sense?
All
right. All right.
Um this is really complicated. Okay. But
for marks the only the what gives rise
to industrial capitalism and the boujo
is just technology and the progress of
history. But as we learn in this class
it's actually much more complicated than
that. Okay. So this is really important.
Okay. What what what we're going to do
is we're going to review what we learned
previously and put them together to
explain what gave roles what gave rise
to industrial capitalism. First thing is
the monophysic revolution. Okay. So
remember before societies were
paganistic or polytheistic then with
Constantine
um God became the Holy Trinity. Okay.
The Holy Trinity is the weirdest idea in
human history. The Holy Trinity is this
God is nothing and
everything. Okay? And what this means is
God is both real and not real. God is a
symbol and reality itself. And because
of this idea, people are now forced to
think abstractly about the world. And it
gives rise to money, nation state and
science. Okay. People are now forced to
think abstractly about the world.
Whereas people were were before could
think very concretely about the world.
Okay. Does that make sense? All right.
Sec. Second thing is gunpowder
revolution where nation states countries
were forced to compete against each
other which led to more industry more
population growth and more
centralization and this paves the way
for the borine now. Okay? Because now
you need the bor to produce industry.
Okay. And the third is the pro
reformation. We discussed this, right?
Where you now have anxiety created by
this new religion. They needed to uh
force themselves to believe they are the
elect. Okay. And then the age of
exploration where the old world Europe
could go and create new markets and
steal new steal gold and bring the
potato corn and tomato back into Europe
which allows for population growth.
Okay. Okay. So in other words, history
is a very complicated process with a lot
of randomness built in. And this is
something that Markx didn't really
understand.
Right? All right. So to summarize, what
people want is status, not class. Okay?
People want to feel distinguished, feel
superior, feel uh that they've achieved
a great deal. The money doesn't really
matter. The money is just a symbol of
this. Okay? People want religion, not
economics. People want God, not heaven.
Okay? And and the proof again is what
happens
um when communism wins. Okay? So both
the Soviet Union and China became
theocracies with coder personalities.
Okay? They were not communist societies.
They were theocracies. They were
religious. They were no different in
many ways than Catholic Europe during
the m during the middle ages. Okay? Um,
Soviet Union fell apart because the
party elite no longer believed in the
system and chose to monetize their
status in power. Okay. And then the
third example is North Korea has a
fertility rate of 1.79 while South Korea
South Korea has a fertility rate of
0.78. Okay. So North Korea it is a
theocratic society. South Korea is a
capitalistic society.
So what do you mean by the code of oh
code of personality is you believe this
person is the manifestation of God all
your hope all your emotions are invested
in this one person right so um so Stalin
right his pictures were everywhere and
in school you learn about how great he
was you worshiped him he was god to you
but same thing with China during the
mong era okay does that make sense so we
call this a call of personality okay
like a new religion based on one person.
All right. Um, so North Korea, which is
poorer than South Korea, has more
children, right? Why? Well,
because people in North Korea, sorry, in
South Korea are miserable. They have
money, but they don't have religion.
They don't have a purpose. They don't
have any meaning. It's all competition.
Okay? So, this is like capitalism run a
mock.
Um then you go to North Korea and he's
president. Okay, he's dead but he's
still president. Why? Because he's
divine. He's God. He is the forever
present. Okay. Kim Ilsun. Okay.
Right. Um
and I mean like I hate to say this, but
if you go to North Korea, they're
probably happier than they are in South
Korea.
Okay. And um the other thing about North
Korea is they're not fighting Ukraine.
So these are people who are willing to
die for what they believe in. So I would
say if if I had to bet which nation um
had the best future, I would bet North
Korea over South
Korea. Okay. Um let's talk about um the
vanguard idea. So for Markx a really
important idea is you need an
intellectual lead to lead the politarian
into
paradise and and this is this is a name
named a man named Macau Buchanan. Okay
Buchanan um and he was an anarchist. He
was he was he was not a communist he was
an anarchist. The difference is this
they both believe in the same thing Marx
and Buchanan but Marx said you need a
vanguard whereas Buchanan said no a
vanguard would destroy everything. Okay,
it has to be spontaneous. It has to be
from the people. Okay. Um, Buchanan is
also lower nobility. His father was a uh
Russian aristocrat. Uh, and Marx and
Buchanan, they were colleagues, but they
hated each other. Right. All right.
Um, so Buchanan believes a lot of things
that Marx believes, right? The freedom
of every other individual does not limit
my own as the individualist claim. On
the contrary, it is confirmation,
realization and human dignity of all
persons to see and feel my freedom
confirmed, sanctioned and balancely
expanded by universal agreement is
happiness. It is human paradise on
earth. So for freedom to be fully
achieved, everyone must be free.
Everyone must be equal. Otherwise
um no one can be truly free. All right.
So
um Buchanan will explain
why a bureaucratic elite will destroy
communism. All right. So this is a very
important passage from
Buchanan. Available to everyone will be
a general scientific education
especially the learning of a scientific
method. The habit of correct thinking
the ability to generalize from facts and
make more or less correct deductions.
But of encyclopic minds and advanced
sociologists there will be very few. It
would be sad for mankind if at any time
theoretic speculation became the only
source of guidance for society. If
science alone were in charge of all
social administration, life would wither
and human society would turn into a
voiceless and survile herd. The
domination of life by science can have
no other result than the brutalization
of mankind. Okay, this is a very
important passage. All this saying is
this. Before we were intellectuals, we
were curious about the world. Now we are
technocrats. We're engineers. We're
taught a very specific skill and we're
taught to see the world in a very
specific way. Okay? And we're run by
technocrats and this has led to the
brutalization of mankind because it has
led to the alienation of mankind, right?
We are now just parts of a
machine. So um an example of course is
AI. So these people in charge now want
to make AI the dominant religion of the
world.
They want to they want to make humans
slave to
AI. Okay? And that's what Bkan is
warning against. Anytime you let a
bureaucratic elite take over, they will
think of ways of how to reinforce the
power for technology. And this has led
to the rise of AI. Okay. Does it make
sense? Okay. And this is describing
China very well, right? The bureaucrats
in charge, they are they have no
imagination. They have no empathy.
All they care about is okay, are we
checking checking off the boxes? Do you
have enough food to eat? Right? Do you
have a job? Well, if you have a house,
if you have a job, you have health
insurance. Why are you complaining?
Right? So, that's what what Buchanan is
saying. All right. Um, the last thing I
want to talk about is this, and you
brought this up earlier, okay? It's a
great question.
Is the question we're looking at today
is why is China so similar to America?
Right? America is a capitalist nation.
China is a communist nation. But if you
talk to Chinese people today, they all
want to go to America to study and
possibly even to live. Chinese want to
become American. So in many ways,
America has conquered China. And so why
is that the case? And the answer, and I
mentioned this before, is it's
because communism and capitalism
reinforce each other. They share a
similar ideology. They share a similar
background. Okay? They're all actually
branch of Christianity really if you
think about it. Okay, they should and
they have a similar worldview, right? A
belief in progress, a belief in class
struggle, a belief that you need a
technocratic elite to run the world. All
right? So, in other words, communism in
China paved the way for American
capitalism. And that's why today you
have this going on. Okay?
what China is doing to children is
unconscionable, right? Because we make
kids sit in school for like 10 hours a
day. They have no childhood. They have
no freedom. They have no happiness. Um
most of these kids will
um develop depression by age 14, right?
the ma vast vast majority there last
week there was a there's a huge news
that a nine-year-old kid in Beijing
killed himself nine years old. Yeah.
Jumped off a building. 9 years old. Um
that's that's incredible because my
oldest son, he's like seven, turning
eight. Okay. I can't I mean I mean like
how miserable does did he have to be to
want to kill himself, right? Even if the
kid succeeds and goes to like Baya or
Chinua, he'll develop depression because
he'll never achieve what he wants in
life. Okay? So, all that's happening is
we're forcing our kids into depression,
into
suicide. Why?
Because this has become an evil religion
almost, right? the belief that through
education you can make more money and
even though everyone else will probably
develop suic will probably probably
develop suicide of depression in the
process you won't. Okay, that that that
I'm betting you won't. Okay, it's it's
it's it's insane. I mean what what
what's happening uh in education today
it it it's just unconscionable and evil
what we're doing to our children in
China, right? And um why we're doing
this is because in China we've combined
communism and capitalism to create the
worst possible society. Okay. All right.
All right. So, um yeah. Any questions?
I have a question to the previous like
the uh I'm talking about like the North
Korea if they really like have such kind
of power even somehow Nazis also
have
well they are still
Uh okay. So why is North Korea so poor?
Okay.
Um so that's part of the capitalist
brainwashing where you measure the su
success success of society based on its
wealth. Okay. But wealth is really um
just the willingness to exploit your
resources. Okay. and also your capacity
to engage in global trade. So, first of
all, North Korea is heavily sanctioned.
They're not allowed to trade with the
world. Okay, that's the first problem.
Um, second problem is
um they focus on their religion is
called self-reliance. They want to be
independent of the world. Okay. So, they
purp purposely choose not to engage in
the world in order to maintain the unity
of their people. Okay? So that's why we
call them the hermit kingdom. For for
them what's important is to maintain
their independence and sovereignty from
from from the world and but that does
not mean people are not happy where they
are. Okay. I would argue that even
though China was a lot poor during the
cult revolution, people were a lot
happier during the cult revolution than
they are today. Maybe not maybe not not
us, okay, but for most ordinary Chinese,
they were a lot happier during the cult
revolution.
um than they are today because for them
life was simple and clear and
certain. Today you have globalization,
you have the internet, you have noise,
you have you it's very confusing for
people, right? And one piece of evidence
is young people don't want to have any
children today. Whereas in the cultural
revolution, people didn't want to have
children because they felt that
regardless of poverty, people were going
into a certain life. They had health
care. They had a job guarantee for them.
They had a sense of community. There was
solidarity going on. Okay. So, um that
really is the trick of capitalism to
make everyone think the same way, which
is like money is
everything. Okay. Does does that make
sense? Yeah. Great. Any more questions?
These are great questions, by the way.
So, so so thank you for for for asking
them.
Markxelves a bit of idealistic.
Yeah. Um so was Markx too idealistic?
Um Markx didn't think it was idealistic.
He thought it was extremely realistic.
Why? Because he was studying all this
history. who was saying all this
economics and he was coming up with a
scientific understanding of the world.
Mark saw himself as a scientist first
and foremost. He saw himself as
unveiling the truth to people. He was do
you understand for him it was science.
It was certain. It was it had to happen.
Okay. Um but the thing about Marx is
this. Marx is also a person that if you
if you were to like jump forward
today and he saw the world created by
communism, capitalism, he would be
utterly disgusted. He wouldn't be like,
"Oh, wow. I'm famous now. I, you know,
I'm the most famous person, one most
famous person in the world. I'm like
Jesus." Okay? He He wouldn't be like
that. He'd be like, "What have we done
to humanity? This is far worse than the
industrial revolution. what's happening
where everyone now is a is a slave as a
consumer right in your mind all that
matters is I go to school I make a lot
of money and I buy a lot of things
that's
it and this would have been unimaginable
to Markx and anyone actually 100 years
ago okay it's it's it's it's a fact that
humanity has chosen to enslave
themselves for like no particular good
reason. Okay. And so the question then
we're looking at next class is why this
happened. And what I'll show you next
class is Simeon Freud had a lot to do
with this. Psychology had a lot to do
with this because before we were focused
on the collective consciousness, right?
The world as it is, the community. But
with coming through psychology, we now
shift our focus to ourselves. So we come
to believe that for our own eternal
struggle we can be happy. Others don't
matter. We ourselves if we're happy
we're good. And what Buchanan and Marks
have taught us is if if everyone is
unhappy, you must be unhappy as well.
It's only if people are free and happy
together can they be free and happy by
themselves. Okay? And that's the thing
that we've forgotten and that's what's
led to the world we live in today. Okay?
But that's something that we'll discuss
next class.
Okay, any more
questions? Great.